.
Der Bundesrat bedauert,
dass die CS nicht in der Lage war,
die Schwierigkeiten
aus eigener Kraft zu meistern.
Es ist das Ende einer Ära.
167 Jahre nach ihrer Gründung
wird die Credit Suisse
von der UBS geschluckt.
Nur so konnte die CS
vor dem Kollaps bewahrt werden.
Wie kann man ein Geschäft führen,
wenn man Milliarden an Boni bezahlt
und Verlust macht?
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Herr Rohner, warum zahlen Sie
diese 52 Mio. Fr. nicht zurück?
Wer übernimmt die Verantwortung
für das Debakel?
... ein absolutes Totalversagen des
Verwaltungsrats über Jahre hinweg.
Zurückzuschauen und mit dem Finger
zu zeigen, ist immer einfach.
Hätte die FINMA früher durchgreifen
müssen bei der CS?
Würde die FINMA
der CS die Bewilligung entziehen,
würde sie ja gekreuzigt werden.
Die UBS ist nun die
mit Abstand grösste Schweizer Bank.
Es kann passieren, dass die UBS
wieder gerettet werden muss.
Finanz- und Bankenkrisen
können nicht verhindert werden.
Dann müsste man
halt Grossbanken zerschlagen
und nur noch
kleinere Banken zulassen.
Denn das Einzige, was sicher ist:
Too big to fail
ist schlicht und ergreifend too big.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Es ist die letzte Generalversammlung
der CS -
gute zwei Wochen nachdem klar ist,
dass die Bank untergeht.
Wissen Sie, was CS heisst?
Chronische Skandale.
Haben Sie Geld verloren?
Ja, sicher.
- Wie viel denn?
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Genug.
Das ist ein Teil meines
Altersgeldes, das ich angelegt habe.
Ich bin traurig, dass es
so weit kam, und ich fordere,
dass die Verantwortlichen
zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden.
Man sollte mal durchgreifen.
- Diese Bank gehörte zur Schweiz.
Ja, schade.
Es ist sehr tragisch
und eine Schande,
dass hier niemand zur Verantwortung
gezogen werden kann.
Was erwarten Sie hier an der GV?
Dass denen mal richtig
der Kopf gewaschen wird.
Am Ende ging alles ganz schnell,
abgezeichnet hat sich
der Untergang der CS
allerdings schon lange.
Rückblende ins Jahr 2022.
Die Credit Suisse
wird zur Serienverlustschreiberin.
Die letzten Illusionen
sind zerstört.
Eine Krise wie diese
hat die Bank jedoch noch nie erlebt.
Alleine in der Schweiz
haben Kunden in diesem Quartal
1,7 Mrd. Fr. von der Bank abgezogen.
Über 10 %
hat die CS-Aktie heute verloren.
Die "Financial Times" in London -
das über die CS stets bestens infor-
mierte Leibblatt der Teppichetagen.
Für Stephen Morris ist klar:
Das Ende der CS
hat sich schon lange abgezeichnet.
Bei der Credit Suisse
gab es immer wieder
sehr ernste und peinliche Skandale,
die die Moral der Mitarbeitenden
und das Vertrauen der Aufsichts-
behörden in die Fähigkeit der Bank,
ihre Kultur zu ändern und
sich zu sanieren, schwinden liessen.
Die Aktionäre
verkauften ihre Aktien.
V.a. aber verliessen
die wohlhabenden Kunden die Bank.
Was wir in den letzten drei Jahren
erlebt haben,
ist der Höhepunkt
eines Jahrzehnts laxen Verhaltens,
schlechter Unternehmenskultur,
schlechter Entscheidungen
und das Versagen der aufeinander
folgenden Managementteams.
Aber auch die Aufsichtsbehörden
und das politische Establishment
in der Schweiz bekamen
die Sache nicht in den Griff.
Ende Oktober 2022:
Die CS versucht, das Ruder mit
einer neuen Strategie herumzureissen.
Was wir heute machen,
ist keine Reorganisation,
sondern wir stellen fundamental
die Weichen für die Zukunft,
sodass wir
eine viel bessere Balance haben.
Die CS
will ihre Investmentbank halbieren,
9'000 Stellen abbauen
und das Eigenkapital stärken.
Der damalige Finanzminister
versucht zu beruhigen.
Eine klare, neue Strategie wurde
verabschiedet und wird umgesetzt.
Das führt zu einer massiven Kosten-
reduktion und vermindert das Risiko.
Sie schafften es, in dieser
Situation Kapital aufzustocken.
Nach einer schlechten Phase
gibt es eine Reihe guter Massnahmen.
Ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass das gelingt.
Die Strategie
war keine radikale Abkehr von dem,
was die Credit Suisse schon
seit mehreren Jahren gemacht hatte.
Es war nur eine
ein bisschen tiefgreifendere
und ein bisschen schnellere Methode,
dies zu tun.
Die Betonung
liegt auf "ein bisschen".
Es war nicht schnell genug.
Sie taten das Richtige, indem sie
die Investmentbank verkleinerten
und versuchten,
das Risiko zu reduzieren.
Aber das Problem war: Sie haben
nicht sehr viel Geld verdient.
Ich denke, das neue Managementteam,
Axel Lehmann als Vorsitzender
und Ueli "das Messer" Körner,
wie er für seine Fähigkeiten
zur Kostensenkung genannt wird,
hatten schlechte Karten.
Sie versuchten, ihr Bestes zu geben,
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob sie jemals
erfolgreich gewesen wären.
Damals wird auch bekannt:
Die Saudi National Bank wird
zur Neuaktionärin der Credit Suisse.
Das Kapital
wird um 4 Mrd. Fr. erhöht,
ein bedeutender Teil davon
kommt aus Riad.
Für Oswald Grübel,
der bei beiden Schweizer Grossbanken,
der CS und der UBS CEO war,
ein kapitaler Fehler.
Da sehen Sie,
wie wenig alle Beteiligten
über das Bankgeschäft wissen,
wenn sie
eine Kapitalerhöhung vornehmen,
wenn die Aktie bei 4 Fr. ist,
also für einen Viertel des Buchwerts
gehandelt wird,
und die Anzahl der Aktien
beinahe verdoppeln.
Was denken Sie, was dann passiert?
Das sagt Ihnen jeder,
der lediglich
über Finanzgrundwissen verfügt:
"Die Aktie wird sich halbieren."
"Und wenn eine schlechte Nachricht
kommt, seid ihr pleite. Fertig."
Dann passiert nämlich ein Run,
denn die Leute
schauen alle auf den Aktienkurs.
Den interessiert es nicht,
was die CS sagt oder kommuniziert.
Um das zu wissen,
muss man kein Genie sein.
Wie ernst es um die CS steht,
ist Ende 2022 offenbar
auch den Schweizer Behörden bewusst,
wie inzwischen bekannt wurde.
Die Situation der Credit Suisse
gibt seit mehreren Monaten
Anlass zur Sorge.
Deshalb hat sich der Bundesrat
in dieser Zeit mehrfach über
den Zustand der Bank unterhalten,
in enger Abstimmung mit der FINMA
und der Schweizer Nationalbank.
Eine entschiedene Intervention Ð
z.B. von der FINMA Ð
bleibt allerdings aus.
Dabei gäbe es
durchaus Ermessensspielraum.
Im Bankengesetz heisst es:
"Besteht begründete Besorgnis,
dass eine Bank überschuldet ist
oder
ernsthafte Liquiditätsprobleme hat",
dann kann die FINMA Schutz-
massnahmen, ein Sanierungsverfahren
oder die Konkursliquidation anordnen.
Die CS verneinte allerdings
bis kurz vor ihrem Ende,
dass es Grund
zu einer solchen Besorgnis gebe.
Aymo Brunetti ist Professor für Wirt-
schaftspolitik und Finanzstabilität.
Dass es in der Theorie
Interventionsmöglichkeiten gebe,
sage noch wenig zur Praxis.
In einer idealen Welt
würde man vorher intervenieren,
vor diesem Wochenende,
an dem man alles entscheiden muss.
Aber stellen Sie sich vor,
die FINMA
hätte im Oktober 2022 gesagt:
"Jetzt muss eine Lösung
für diese Bank gefunden werden,
sie kann so
nicht weiter existieren."
Das hätte einen Aufschrei gegeben.
Man hätte gesagt:
"Lasst diese Bank arbeiten."
"Jetzt macht sie Massnahmen, sie hat
genügend Kapital und Liquidität."
"Wie kommt die FINMA dazu,
so etwas zu machen?"
Auch wenn das an sich richtig
gewesen wäre, wenn das rauskommt,
muss diese Komponente
ebenfalls betrachtet werden.
Taten
müssen plausibel erklärt werden.
Den Vorwurf, bei der CS nicht tätig
geworden zu sein, weise er zurück,
sagt der FINMA-Direktor.
Natürlich mussten wir
bei der CS immer wieder eingreifen.
Diese Bank
hat einen hohen Risikoappetit
und keine
besonders gute Risikokultur.
Darum taten wir das immer wieder.
Gehorchte die Bank Ihnen nicht?
Die CS hat Massnahmen ergriffen.
Wir ordneten Massnahmen an,
die CS setzte sie auch um.
Sie tauchten aber immer wieder
in verschiedenen Bereichen auf.
Reto Schiltknecht war bis 2021
Kadermann bei der FINMA.
Auch die Angst vor einem Misserfolg
könne bei Interventionen
eine Rolle spielen,
sagt er aus Erfahrung.
Man geht hin, ordnet eine Massnahme
an und fällt auf die Schnauze.
Das ist das Schlimmste,
was einem passieren kann.
Als FINMA muss diese Erwägung
permanent gemacht werden.
Wie sind die Chancen?
Diese Chancen waren nicht immer gut,
auch wenn die Öffentlichkeit dachte,
es sei eine Katastrophe.
Es läuft nicht nur eine Sache.
Ich könnte noch 100 Fälle aufzählen.
Auch Ressourcenprobleme?
- Ja, das kommt auch dazu.
Ich kann nicht jede Baustelle,
jeden Strassengraben aufreissen.
Es ist also eine gewisse Ohnmacht da?
- Bis zu einem gewissen Grad schon.
Die FINMA-Interventionen haben die CS
offenbar wenig beeindruckt.
In Zürich-West treffen wir
zwei ehemalige CS-Bankerinnen,
die hier seit drei Jahren
ihre eigene Firma führen.
Die Kultur hat einerseits
kurzfristiges Handeln toleriert,
wenn nicht unterstützt.
Andererseits
wurden kritische Stimmen -
ich sage es etwas plakativ -
ausgeschaltet.
Das ist das grundlegende
Kulturproblem, das vorhanden war.
In Kombination
mit dem Vergütungssystem
verstärkte sich das
gegenseitig sicher noch.
Tonia Zimmermann - von 2007 bis 2019
bei der CS in leitender Position
im Bereich der Derivate,
der Fondsanalysten
und der Anlagespezialisten
für Schweizer Kunden.
Luba Schönig -
von 2006 bis 2014 bei der CS
im Bereich der Derivate
und später zuständig
für Anlage- und Kreditlösungen
der grössten Kunden Osteuropas.
Sehr wichtig ist:
Der Bankenindustrie,
wie es momentan der Status quo ist,
scheint die Seele
abhandengekommen zu sein.
Bezieht man sich nur
auf die Kompensation,
und sagt, "Stellen wir sicher,
dass wir genug Geld bekommen,
dann bleiben die Leute schon",
dann kauft man die Leute.
Aber kauft - oder sichert -
man wirklich ihr Engagement?
Sind sie wirklich motiviert?
Fühlen sie sich wohl?
Die Kultur eines Unternehmens
und das Humankapital
sind die wichtigsten Ressourcen.
Warum haben das Risk Management
und all diese Kontrollen
bei der CS versagt?
Das geht auf die Kultur zurück.
Diese Kultur wurde akzeptiert.
Viele Entscheidungen,
die getroffen wurden,
erbrachten hauptsächlich gewissen
Situationen und Individuen
kurzfristige Gewinne.
Das war erwünscht
und wurde toleriert.
Die mittel- und längerfristigen
Interessen der Bank
gerieten vielleicht
ein Stück weit in den Hintergrund.
Ich denke, das ist im Endeffekt
das Kernproblem.
Heute geben die beiden
ihr Wissen an der Uni Zürich weiter.
Ihr Publikum:
Banking- und Finance-Studierende.
Ihnen erzählen sie von der Investi-
tionsplattform, die sie betreiben,
die es nicht-professionellen Anlegern
ermöglichen soll, zu investieren.
Uns liegt am Herzen,
dass Finanzinformationen
einfach zugänglich
zur Verfügung gestellt werden
sowie leicht
und intuitiv verständlich sind.
Das Ende der CS
beschäftigt auch die Studierenden.
Was hören Sie von Leuten,
die bei der Credit Suisse arbeiten?
Viele Wirtschaftstudierende hier
haben auch Eltern,
die im Bankensektor arbeiten.
Diese Eltern wissen jetzt
nicht genau, wie es weitergeht.
V.a. diejenigen, die bei der CS
oder der UBS arbeiten.
Ich habe einige Freunde, bei denen
zu Hause nicht ganz sicher ist,
wie es weitergeht.
Man hat in den Nachrichten
sehr viel gehört.
Es gingen viele Informationen rum.
Ich kenne auch einige,
die das direkt betrifft.
Leute, die wegen der Überschnei-
dungen um ihren Job bangen müssen.
Ich finde das schon recht krass,
v.a. für uns als Banking-Studenten.
Das sind Arbeitsplätze,
die irgendwann von uns
hätten besetzt werden können.
Hoffen wir, dass sich alles
ein wenig reguliert.
Es ist viel Trauer und Ohnmacht
im Spiel.
Auch bei mir. Ich durfte viel
von dieser Bank profitieren.
Es ist wirklich
ein sehr emotionaler Moment.
Neben der ganzen Verunsicherung
steht sicher auch
eine Betroffenheit im Raum.
Und natürlich auch sehr viel Wut.
Das muss man auch sagen.
Viele sind richtig wütend,
dass es so weit gekommen ist.
Die Wurzeln der Credit Suisse
reichen zurück bis ins Jahr 1856.
Damals entstand
die Schweizerische Kreditanstalt -
mitgegründet vom grossen Politiker,
Wirtschaftsführer und
Eisenbahnunternehmer Alfred Escher.
Escher brauchte eine eigene Bank,
um seine ehrgeizigen Eisenbahnpläne
zu finanzieren.
Der Bau des Gotthardtunnels - ohne
Escher und seine Hausbank undenkbar.
Wirtschaftshistoriker
Tobias Straumann sagt,
das Spiel mit Risiken habe
schon immer zum Wesen der CS gehört.
Die Geschichte der CS
ist sehr turbulent.
Es war von Anfang an eine Bank,
die die grossen Geschäfte machte -
auch internationale Geschäfte.
V.a. sehr volatile Geschäfte.
Sie begann
mit der Eisenbahnfinanzierung,
das war extrem anspruchsvoll.
Es ging hoch und runter.
Die damalige Kreditanstalt
stand schon nach zehn Jahren
nahe am Abgrund.
Das gehört zur DNA dieser Bank.
Sie war eine Bank,
die immer hart am Wind segelte.
Als die Kreditanstalt
die Volksbank schluckt,
entsteht die CS,
wie wir sie heute kennen.
Bilder aus dem Jahr 1993.
Der starke Mann ist damals Verwal-
tungsratspräsident Rainer E. Gut.
Er hat grosse Pläne mit der Bank.
Die Schweiz war mir immer zu klein.
Darum haben wir einen grossen Teil
unseres Geschäfts im Ausland.
Auf kritische Nachfragen reagiert der
frühere Wall-Street-Banker gereizt.
Sie gerieten in letzter Zeit in die
Schlagzeilen im Zusammenhang mit d...
Nein, wissen Sie,
irgendwo hört es auf.
Mit den Bilanzsummen
wächst auch das Ego der CS-Banker.
"Bescheidener Superstar" -
solche Schlagzeilen
lassen sich CS-Kader wie Lukas
Mühlemann dagegen gerne gefallen.
Die Banker als moderne Helden:
zwar fürstlich entlöhnt,
aber wegen ihrer Kompetenz
jeden Franken wert.
Dieses Bild bekommt spätestens beim
Swissair-Grounding 2001 tiefe Risse.
Im Verwaltungsrat sassen nämlich auch
CS-Banker wie Lukas Mühlemann.
Aus Helden werden Buhmänner.
Der Verwaltungsratspräsident
wechselt in der Folge bei der CS,
die Haltung dagegen nicht.
2003 übernimmt Walter Kielholz
das Ruder.
Unter ihm wird
der Deutsche Oswald Grübel CEO.
Bei den Gehältern
geht es nun steil aufwärts.
Die Geschäftsleitung
kassiert im Durchschnitt
20 Mio. pro Person und Jahr.
Würden Sie heute sagen: "Jetzt sehe
ich das. Es war vielleicht zu viel."
Natürlich war es vielleicht zu viel,
aber wenn Sie mich fragen,
was Sie vielleicht interessiert
oder worauf Sie hinauswollen:
Habe ich ein schlechtes Gewissen?
Nein.
Was ist gerecht?
Wenn wir damit anfangen ...
Die ganze Welt ist ungerecht.
Fertig. Mir können Sie kein schlech-
tes Gewissen einreden, tut mir leid.
Auf Oswald Grübel folgt 2007
der Amerikaner Brady Dougan,
der bis dahin
die Investmentbank leitete.
Unter Dougan geht die Boni-Bonanza
jetzt richtig los.
Das ist für mich
ein typisches Beispiel.
Er ist jemand,
der aus dem Investmentbanking kommt
und kein Interesse daran hatte,
das abzubauen.
Er stellte beim Lohn
unverschämte Forderungen.
Und man merkte: Ihn interessiert
die Schweiz überhaupt nicht.
Er war eine völlige Fehlbesetzung
für eine Schweizer Bank,
deren Kern die Vermögensverwaltung
und das Schweizer Geschäft ist.
Ich finde, dort fing es an,
bei dieser Besetzung.
Man merkte: Was ist das
für eine seltsame Personalpolitik?
Wer kommt hier eigentlich zum Zug?
Gibt es nicht andere,
die das besser können?
Zur gleichen Zeit,
als Dougan sein Amt antritt,
überhitzt sich
der amerikanische Immobilienmarkt.
Die Hypothekarzinsen steigen.
Die Hausbesitzer können sie nicht
mehr bezahlen und müssen ausziehen.
Damit verlieren
nicht nur die Häuser massiv an Wert,
sondern auch Hypotheken-Wertpapiere,
sog. Subprime-Papiere.
* Beunruhigende Klänge *
Im Jahr darauf, 2008,
geht Lehman Brothers,
eine amerikanische Bank, pleite -
der Auftakt
des grossen Zusammenbruchs.
* Beunruhigende Klänge *
Nach der Immobilienblase platzt
jetzt auch noch die Kreditblase.
Kurssturz.
* Glocke *
Die UBS steht nun am Abgrund.
Denn sie hatte eine aggressive Expan-
sionsstrategie in den USA verfolgt.
Sie ist sehr exponiert am amerikani-
schen Immobilien- und Derivatemarkt.
Sie schreibt Verluste
in Milliardenhöhe.
Der Schweizer Staat
muss die UBS retten.
Darf ich Ihnen etwas abnehmen?
- Den nassen Schirm, bitte.
Denn die UBS ist too big to fail -
zu gross, um untergehen zu können.
Wir verstehen
das Engagement des Bundes
als Engagement für den Finanz-
kreislauf, auch unter den Banken.
Wir verstehen es als Engagement,
als Unterstützung für die KMU,
für die vielen KMU in der Schweiz,
die intensiven Bankenverkehr haben.
Wir verstehen es
als Engagement für die Wirtschaft.
Dass Bund und Nationalbank der UBS
mit 68 Mrd. Fr.
unter die Arme greifen müssen,
lässt die Emotionen hochgehen.
Mit ihrer masslosen Gier
haben die Investmentbanker
die Weltwirtschaft
nahezu an den Abgrund gebracht.
Der Staat soll künftig
bei einer solchen Krise
nicht mehr einspringen müssen.
Dafür sollte die Politik sorgen.
Too big to fail.
- Too big to fail.
Too big to fail -
zu gross, um unterzugehen.
Wie rettet man
eine Bank ohne Steuergeld?
Eine Expertenkommission
debattiert zwei Jahre lang.
Unter der Leitung
des Finanzdepartementes.
Die Zusammenarbeit
in der aus Vertretern von Behörden,
der Wissenschaft, der Realwirtschaft
und dem Finanzsektor
zusammengesetzten Kommission
war intensiv.
Wir haben jetzt ein Paket geschnürt,
von dem wir überzeugt sind,
dass es massgeblich zur Begrenzung
der Too-big-to-fail-Risiken
beitragen wird.
Die Kommission fordert:
Grossbanken müssen mehr Eigenkapital
und Liquidität halten.
Und: Im Notfall müsste eine Bank
aufgespaltet werden können.
Die Tochtergesellschaften im Ausland
gingen Konkurs.
Der Schweizer Teil der Bank aber
würde überleben
und weiter funktionieren.
Ziel der Massnahmen
gegen dieses Too-big-to-Fail
muss es daher sein,
den Steuerzahler aus dieser
ungewollten Haftung zu entlassen.
Rolf Soiron,
Mitglied der Expertenkommission.
Damals, 2010,
ein Schwergewicht der Wirtschaft -
als ehemaliger Verwaltungsrats-
präsident von Lonza und Holcim.
Erinnern Sie sich an Fronten
bei diesen Aufspaltungen?
Nein. Es wurde gewarnt davor,
dass in Anerkennung
von Verflechtungen
die innerhalb von Organisationen
bestehen,
die Aufspaltung dann im Einzelfall
vielleicht
gar nicht so einfach zu machen ist.
Davor wurde gewarnt.
Aber die Ausgliederung
des schweizerischen Kerngeschäfts
mit den entscheidenden Elementen,
die auch für die Bevölkerung
und die Wirtschaft dieses Landes
bedeutend sind - Zahlungsverkehr,
Spargeschäft, Hypothekargeschäft -
war unbestritten
im Instrumentenkasten.
Waren Sie auch dafür?
- Ja, absolut.
Im Ständerat herrschte heute
Einigkeit wie selten.
Ohne Gegenstimme wurde die Too-big-
to-fail-Vorlage gutgeheissen.
(Originalbeitrag)
36:0 bei zwei Enthaltungen.
Trotz langer Diskussion stehen
am Ende alle politischen Lager
hinter den neuen Regeln.
Wir wollen Gewähr haben, dass
eine Bank auch Konkurs gehen kann.
Das Ende der Credit Suisse.
- Aus zwei Banken wird eine Bank.
Eine Traditionsbank stirbt,
ein neuer Gigant entsteht.
Basierend
auf der Notverordnung des Bundesrats
können Credit Suisse und UBS
ein Liquiditätshilfedarlehen
in der Höhe von insgesamt
bis zu 100 Mrd. Fr. beziehen.
Zusätzlich dazu und basierend
auf der Notverordnung des Bundesrats
kann die Nationalbank
der Credit Suisse
ein mit einer Ausfallgarantie
des Bundes gesichertes
Liquiditätshilfedarlehen in der Höhe
von bis zu 100 Mrd. Fr. gewähren.
Notrecht?
Wieder milliardenschwere Garantien
vom Steuerzahler?
Was ist mit dem Too-big-to-fail-Plan?
Warum wurde er nicht angewendet?
Warum hat man nicht einfach
die Gruppe Konkurs gehen lassen
und das Schweiz-Geschäft
weitergeführt?
Das ist bei einer so grossen system-
relevanten Bank noch nie passiert.
Die Verbindungen zwischen der UBS
und der Credit Suisse sind eng -
auch mit den anderen Banken und auf
den internationalen Finanzmärkten.
Das hätte mit ziemlicher Sicherheit
eine Finanzkrise ausgelöst.
Wir haben 15 Jahre
quasi für nichts gearbeitet.
Wir weisen seit Jahren
auf diese Lücke hin.
Jetzt stehen wir
vor einem Scherbenhaufen.
Genau für diesen Fall
haben wir das Gesetz verabschiedet.
Und im ersten Anwendungsfall
kann es nicht angewendet werden.
Wir wollen Antworten vom Bundesrat.
(Oswald Grübel) Es war nie
eine Option. Es war ein Traum.
Es hätte ein Signal
an den Rest der Welt gesendet.
Man hätte sich gesagt:
In dem Moment, wo es schwierig wird,
nimmt sich die Schweiz
das Filetstück,
das Schweizer Business,
das Kundengeschäft.
Und das Ausland darf sich
mit dem Rest herumschlagen -
mit dem schwierigeren Problem.
Wir wären erledigt -
als Land, als Finanzplatz.
Aymo Brunetti gilt als Vater
der Too-big-to-fail-Gesetzgebung.
War seine Arbeit umsonst?
Wenn man nach der Analyse
dieses Falls zum Schluss kommt,
dass man immer staatliche
Solvenzhilfe geben müsste,
keine Liquiditätshilfe,
dann bin ich auch der Meinung,
dass die Banken
in letzter Konsequenz
eine Staatsgarantie haben -
das ist inakzeptabel.
Wenn die Einschätzung ist,
dass das ursprüngliche Konzept,
nicht nur in der Schweiz,
sondern global, in plausiblen Krisen
nicht funktioniert,
braucht es andere Massnahmen.
War man naiv?
Ja, im Nachhinein
ist jede Generation naiv.
Wir lernen immer dazu.
Wir konnten es damals
nicht voraussehen.
Wahrscheinlich weil niemand
bei der Beratung dabei war,
der das Geschäft kennt.
Sie haben jemanden
von Ihren UBS-Leuten
in die Expertenkommission geschickt.
Hat er nicht gewarnt?- Ich weiss
es nicht. Ich war nicht dabei.
Es waren drei Banker
in der Expertenkommission.
Der Rest waren Professoren und
sonstige Leute aus der Wirtschaft.
Ausserdem stand ich täglich im
Austausch mit Kollegen im Ausland.
Insbesondere Kollegin Janet Yellen
aus den USA
und Jeremy Hunt in UK.
Beide Finanzplätze sind wichtig.
Auch auf diesen Finanzplätzen -
UK und USA -
spielt die Credit Suisse
eine wichtige Rolle.
Als sich das Problem zuspitzte,
entstand
immenser internationaler Druck.
Es sah so aus,
als ob die Credit Suisse
eine schwere
Vertrauenskrise erleiden könnte.
Infolgedessen begannen Leute
hier im Vereinigten Königreich,
aber auch in Frankreich
und bei der US-Notenbank,
starken Druck
auf die Schweizer auszuüben.
Ein Insider beschrieb, sie hätten
die Schweizer in den Arsch getreten.
Eine umgangssprachliche Art
zu sagen,
dass sie die Schweizer drängten,
die Krise in den Griff zu bekommen.
Ich vermute, es war der Druck.
Das Ausland hat verlangt,
dass wir zu einer raschen,
klar kommunizierbaren,
gut darstellbaren Lösung kommen.
Wenn die Schweiz
vielleicht gesagt hätte,
dass sie alles garantiert,
dass sie zahlen, was es braucht,
hätte es zu einer möglichen
oder minimalen Beruhigung
der Weltmärkte geführt.
"Whatever it takes", "was immer
nötig ist" - das zentrale Stichwort.
Hinter dem Zürcher Paradeplatz
treffen wir den Mann,
der bei der Finanzmarktaufsicht
für den Bereich Too big to fail
verantwortlich war:
Reto Schiltknecht.
Er sagt, die Arbeiten
für die Aufspaltung einer Bank
seien nicht abgeschlossen.
Die Liquiditätskonzepte im Konkurs
sind offen.
Das ist die Achillesferse
des Ganzen.
Beim Konkurs der weltweit tätigen
CS-Bank mit Sitz in der Schweiz
hätten v.a. die Bankkunden
der Zweigniederlassungen im Ausland
Verluste erlitten - v.a.
in New York, Singapur und Hongkong.
Wären ihre Einlagen nicht
durch die Banken gedeckt gewesen,
hätte wohl der Bund
einspringen müssen -
mit dem sog. Public Liquidity
Backstop, einem Schutzschirm.
Garantiert von ...
den Schweizer Steuerzahlenden.
Ein Gesetz dafür
gibt es aber noch nicht.
Der Public Liquidity Backstop ist
quasi das letzte Sicherheitsnetz.
Wenn die Bank
keine Sicherheiten mehr hat
und die Zentralbank nur Liquidität
gegen Sicherheiten geben kann,
dann kommt der "lender of the last
last resort", nämlich der Bund,
der der SNB eine Sicherheit gibt,
damit sie Liquidität geben kann.
Die Bank hat zwar keine mehr,
aber der Bund springt ein.
Verstehe ich das richtig?
Die Schweizern Steuerzahlenden
hätten am Ende Milliarden Garantien
für die Gläubiger der CS-Töchter
im Ausland sprechen müssen.
Ja, das ist ...
Das schwingt mit, ja.
Davor hatte man am Ende
Respekt im Parlament.
Das ist der entscheidende Punkt.
Man fragte sich im Parlament,
weshalb der Schweizer Steuerzahler
für Gläubiger im Ausland
garantieren muss.
Seit der UBS-Rettung
hat man dem Volk versprochen,
keine Staatshilfe mehr zu sprechen,.
Dem Volk wurde Sand in die Augen
gestreut.- Das kann man so sagen.
Die Kommunikation
war manchmal eher kollusiv.
Die FINMA,
das muss man selbstkritisch sagen,
hätte meiner Meinung nach
proaktiver kommunizieren können.
Sie hätte auch mal sagen können,
dass es noch Risiken gibt.
Diese Risiken
müssen adressiert werden.
Man muss aber auch sagen,
dass der PLB auch in anderen
Szenarien zu tragen gekommen wäre.
Wenn man z.B. eine Verstaatlichung
der Bank angestrebt hätte, wenn
der Bund die Bank übernommen hätte,
hätte es das auch gebraucht.
Oder auch bei einer Sanierung.
Dieser PLB, diese vorübergehende
Zurverfügungstellung der Liquidität,
wäre in allen Szenarien,
die wir auf dem Radar hatten,
zur Anwendung gekommen.
Muss man davon ausgehen, dass alle
systemrelevanten Banken der Welt,
damit auch der Schweiz, wissen:
Im Zweifelsfall
haben wir staatliche Garantien.
Ja, bis zu einem gewissen Grad.
* Protestrufe *
Die Bilder erinnern an 2008.
Wieder wird
auf dem Paradeplatz demonstriert.
Wieder wegen der Staatsrettung
einer Grossbank. Diesmal jene der CS.
Dass die CS
nun gerettet werden musste,
hat vermutlich viel damit zu tun,
dass sie es 2008
besser gemacht hat als die UBS.
Man muss aber aufpassen:
Die Credit Suisse hatte einen
Rekordverlust in der Geschichte.
Sie hat nur überlebt,
weil die UBS gestützt wurde.
Hätte man das nicht getan, wäre sie
auch in den Strudel geraten.
Am Ende hätte sie auch
Staatshilfe gebraucht.
Aber sie kam auch voll
in die Verlustzone hinein.
Es ist nicht so,
dass sie es glorios überstanden hat.
Bei der CS
führte die globale Finanzkrise
allerdings nicht zu einem Umdenken.
Trotz Riesenverlust wurden
2 Mrd. Boni ausbezahlt für 2008.
Jeder Mitarbeiter in dieser Bank,
in jeglicher Funktion,
hat das Anrecht darauf,
dass seine individuelle Leistung
beurteilt wird -
v.a. in einem Tätigkeitsbereich
ohne Gesamtverantwortung.
Wir haben versucht,
das ausgewogen zu beantworten.
Wir haben auch Mitarbeiter,
die sehr erfolgreich waren.
Jetzt gehen die Lohnexzesse
erst richtig los.
Brady Dougan, ab 2007 CEO, ist die
Verkörperung dieser Masslosigkeit.
2009 bezieht er ein Gehalt von
20 Mio. plus einen Bonus von 70 Mio.
Mit einer Gesamtentlöhnung
von 90 Mio. Fr.
ist Dougan nun
der bestbezahlte Bankmanager Europas.
Diese Exzesse wollte Thomas Minder
mit der Abzocker-Initiative stoppen.
Die Aktionäre sollten die Gehälter
an den Generalversammlungen
nach unten korrigieren können.
Aber irgendetwas ist schiefgelaufen.
Denn die Aktionäre sind
nach der Annahme seiner Initiative
nicht eingeschritten bei der CS.
Der Aktionär ist mitverantwortlich.
Er hat jedes Mal ...
Übrigens auch Institutionelle:
Actaris, Ethos,
der AHV-Ausgleichsfonds ...
Sie haben diese Vergütungen gutge-
heissen an der Generalversammlung.
Sie wählten die Leute
wieder in den Verwaltungsrat.
Sie wählten die Leute sogar
wieder in die Risikoüberwachung.
Im Verwaltungsrat setzt sich jemand
mit der Risikoevaluation
auseinander.
Und auch ins Compensation Committee
wurden sie wieder gewählt.
Der Aktionär ist also auch
für das Geschehen mitverantwortlich.
Ist das der Scherbenhaufen
Ihrer Initiative?
Gut, das höre ich jetzt.
Aber es wäre doch verrückt,
wenn man an der Generalversammlung
nicht über die Vergütungssumme
abstimmen könnte.
Die Initiative wurde
vor zehn Jahren, 2013, angenommen.
Ohne sie
wäre es noch schlimmer geworden.
Es führte bei den einen oder anderen
Unternehmungen zur Mässigung.
Es gibt die Abgangsentschädigung
und die Vorauszahlungen nicht mehr.
Es gibt auch nicht mehr die Beträge
wie bei Brady Dougan, 70 Mio.,
Vasella, 72 Mio.
Es sind 11-13 Mio.
Das ist auch noch viel.
Das ist auch noch Abzockerei. Aber
es ist zumindest stehen geblieben.
Die Banken
müssten besser beaufsichtigt werden.
Nicht nur von den Aktionären,
sondern von einer starken Behörde,
hiess es nach der Krise 2008.
Die Eidgenössischen Bankenkommission,
kurz EBK,
sei mit den Risiken des Finanzplatzes
überfordert.
Darum wird die Finanzmarktaufsicht,
kurz FINMA, gegründet.
Sie soll fortan
alle Bereiche des Finanzwesens,
insbesondere auch Banken,
beaufsichtigen und kontrollieren.
Peter V. Kunz ist der Ansicht,
dass mit der FINMA
eine Behörde geschaffen wurde,
die im Grunde zahnlos ist.
Die FINMA ist heute
sehr schwach ausgestaltet.
Ausländische Aufsichtsbehörden
haben wesentlich
weiter gehende Kompetenzen.
Man weiss jetzt auch,
dass die CS
relativ unwirsch reagiert hat
auf Verfügungen der FINMA.
Die FINMA hat gesagt,
sie sollen etwas tun.
Die letzten Tage hiess es, es
seien Verfügungen erlassen worden,
aber die CS
hätte sie nicht sauber umgesetzt.
Die setzt das doch nicht um, wenn
sie weiss, dass ihr nichts passiert.
Die FINMA hatte keine Drohmittel.
Dass die FINMA kritisiert wird,
ist nicht neu.
Bisher allerdings nicht etwa,
weil sie zu zahm wäre,
im Gegenteil:
Den Bankern war sie zu mächtig.
Wir fordern, dass die FINMA das tut,
wofür sie vorgesehen ist:
FINMA bedeutet Finanzmarktaufsicht
und nicht Finanzmarktregulierung.
Die FINMA soll nur dort regulieren,
wo dies
mit Blick auf die Aufsichtszwecke
auch wirklich
und absolut notwendig ist.
Wenn sie das nicht tut,
überschreitet sie ihre Kompetenz.
Den einen zu mächtig,
den anderen zu zahm -
in diesem Spannungsfeld
bewegt sich die FINMA.
Sie müssen verstehen:
Es gibt immer zwei Seiten.
Natürlich will niemand
mehr reguliert werden,
weil es in der Geschäftstätigkeit
einschränkt.
Möglichst wenig Aufsicht,
das war auch der CS recht.
2011 bekommt sie einen
neuen Verwaltungsratspräsidenten,
Urs Rohner, einen Juristen.
Ich habe nie
in einem Handelsraum gearbeitet.
Das ist für dieses Amt
auch keine unbedingte Notwendigkeit.
Ich habe die letzten sieben Jahre
viel über Bankrisiken gelernt.
Brady Dougan kann unter Urs Rohner
sein risikoreiches Investmentbanking
ungestört betreiben.
Beide Grossbanken haben ab sofort
eine unterschiedliche Strategie.
Die UBS
hat ihre Investmentbank degradiert
zum Wurmfortsatz
der Vermögensverwaltung.
Und Sie sagen weiterhin:
Die Investmentbank ist eine Säule
in unserem Geschäft und bleibt so.
Zur Strategie der UBS kann und will
ich mich nicht detailliert äussern.
Was uns betrifft:
Wir sind überzeugt davon,
dass unsere Strategie
für unsere Bank die richtige ist,
wenn wir in Geschäften sind,
die nachhaltig ertragswirksam und
profitabel betrieben werden können.
Und Geschäfte, die sich in Märkten
als stark herausstellen werden,
die in den nächsten Jahren
stark wachsen werden.
Unter Urs Rohner produziert die CS
zahlreiche Skandale.
Ihre noch offenen Rechtsfälle
übernimmt nun die UBS.
Der Fall Mozambique.
Zwischen 2013 und 2016
vergab die CS in Mozambique
Kredite für den Aufbau
einer Fischfangflotte
und für Schellboote
für die Küstenwache.
Die CS soll in Korruption und
Schmiergeldzahlungen verwickelt sein,
Mozambique
musste Staatsbankrott anmelden.
Im Oktober 2023 steht ein Prozess
vor dem englischen High Court an.
Es könnte zu einer Milliardenzahlung
an die Kläger kommen.
Der Fall FIFA.
2015 hat die US-Justiz
Anklage erhoben
gegen Personen und Organisationen
im Umfeld der FIFA.
Im Zuge dieser Ermittlungen erhielt
auch die CS Anfragen der US-Justiz.
U.a. geht es um Geldwäsche.
Der Verwaltungsrat der CS bekommt
die Probleme nicht in den Griff,
kassiert aber fleissig ab.
Nach Brady Dougan,
der den aalglatten Banker
geradezu perfekt verkörpert,
übernimmt nun
eine schillernde Persönlichkeit
mit Charme und Emotionen.
Wie Sie sehen,
meine geschätzten Damen und Herren:
Mein Deutsch
ist etwas rostig geworden.
2015 wird Tidjane Thiam,
ivorisch-französischer Doppelbürger,
CEO der CS.
Dougans Nachfolger kommt
von einer englischen Versicherung
und soll die CS
strategisch neu ausrichten -
weg vom
risikoreichen Investmentbanking.
Brady Dougan hat in acht Jahren
160 Mio. verdient,
der Aktienkurs fiel derweil um 64 %.
Der Wechsel von Dougan zu Thiam
soll auch
ein imagemässiger Neuanfang sein.
Endlich raus
aus den Negativschlagzeilen.
Mit Thiam lief es auch nicht gut.
Er hatte grosse Verdienste
mit der Prudential,
der Versicherung in London,
die er offenbar
erfolgreich neu ausgerichtet hatte.
Aber er hat es
auch nicht hingekriegt.
Es hat sich sehr früh gezeigt,
dass sein Führungsstil nicht
zu dieser Schweizer Bank passt.
Er führte viel zu hierarchisch.
Das griff die Firmenkultur
extrem an.
Es ist nicht erstaunlich, dass es
am Ende so herausgekommen ist.
Unter Thiam
gehen die Skandale weiter.
Anfang 2020 kann er den Medien
einen satten Gewinn von über 3 Mrd.
präsentieren.
Gleichzeitig tritt er als CEO zurück.
Gestolpert ist er über ihn:
Iqbal Khan.
The next generation
is sometimes portrayed
as a privileged group of people
who are lacking ambition.
Based on my own experience
this is far from the truth.
Iqbal Khan, Chef der internationalen
Vermögensverwaltung der CS,
wurde nach seinem Abgang
zur Konkurrentin UBS
von Privatdetektiven überwacht.
Aus meiner Sicht, aber auch aus
Sicht des gesamten Verwaltungsrats,
war diese Auftragsüberwachung
falsch und unangemessen,
auch wenn sie subjektiv
zum Schutz der Interessen
der Gesellschaft angeordnet wurde.
Die getroffene Massnahme
war nicht verhältnismässig
und entspricht nicht
den Kriterien und Massstäben,
die wir an unsere Arbeit legen.
Später kommt heraus: Es wurden
noch andere Mitarbeiter überwacht.
Der Druck wird zu gross.
Tidjane Thiam muss Anfang 2020 gehen.
In seinen fünf Jahren
bei der Credit Suisse
kassierte er insgesamt 90 Mio. Fr.
Der Aktienkurs
fiel in seiner Amtszeit um 55 %.
Die Skandale gehen derweil weiter
bei der CS
und werden nach der Übernahme
durch die UBS nun zu deren Problem.
Weil das teuer werden kann,
hat der Bundesrat vorgesorgt.
Konkret hat der Bundesrat
eine Garantie
im Umfang von 9 Mrd. Fr. gesprochen,
um allfällige Risiken der UBS
zu reduzieren.
Was genau damit gemeint ist,
ist unklar. Klar ist indes:
Es gibt auch noch
den Fall Steuerstreit USA.
2014 musste sich die damalige
CS-Spitze vor dem US-Senat
wegen Beihilfe zur Steuerhinter-
ziehung von US-Bürgern verantworten.
Der damalige CEO Brady Dougan schwor,
dass es nie mehr vorkäme.
Es gab Mitarbeiter, die wissentlich
gegen US-Recht verstiessen.
Obwohl ich sehr bestürzt bin
über ihr Fehlverhalten,
stellt sich das Management
der Vergangenheit
und übernimmt die Verantwortung.
Die CS
zahlte eine Busse von 2,6 Mrd. ¤.
Weil sie unterschrieb,
nie mehr ein solches Verhalten
an den Tag zu legen, gab es
eine Ermässigung von 1,3 Mrd. ¤.
Diese Geschichte könnte die CS
und mit ihr die UBS nun einholen.
Denn gemäss einem Bericht
des US-Senats
habe die Bank nicht aufgehört,
US-Steuerpflichtigen beim
Hinterziehen von Steuern zu helfen.
Breaking News Ende März 2023
auf dem US-Sender CNBC.
Das Finanzkomitee des Senats
veröffentlicht zur Stunde
einen neuen Bericht,
in dem die Anschuldigungen von
Informanten gegen die Credit Suisse
detailliert aufgeführt sind.
Im Bericht wird behauptet,
dass die CS amerikanischen Kunden
dabei geholfen hat,
Hunderte von Millionen Dollar
vor dem Finanzamt zu verstecken,
obwohl sie sich vor zehn Jahren
zur Zusammenarbeit mit den US-
Steuerbehörden verpflichtet hatte.
Geleitet wurde die zweijährige
Untersuchung von Senator Ron Wyden.
Die Ermittlungen dauern noch an.
Gerade in den letzten Tagen
wurde festgestellt,
dass noch mehr Geld
unterschlagen wurde.
Es gibt hier
einige sehr wichtige Fragen.
Die CS schreibt:
Basis des Reports sind Aussagen von
Whistleblowern: ehemalige CS-Banker.
Ihr Anwalt ist Jeff Neiman.
Die Informationen seiner Klienten
führten dazu,
dass zahlreiche nicht deklarierte
CS-Konten von US-Steuerpflichtigen
zum Vorschein kamen.
Seine Klienten
haben ein finanzielles Interesse.
Denn wenn die CS
dank ihnen erneut gebüsst wird,
bekommen sie einen Anteil.
Sie haben soeben vor dem
Finanzkomitee des Senats zugegeben,
dass sie geholfen haben,
nach 2014
mehr als 700 Mio. ¤ zu verstecken.
Das ist ein Verstoss
gegen ihr Versprechen.
Deshalb stecken sie heute
in Schwierigkeiten.
Vor seiner Tätigkeit als Anwalt
war Jeff Neiman
ein hochdekorierter US-Staatsanwalt.
Beim UBS-Fall 2008 war er
einer der führenden Staatsanwälte.
Zum Abschied schenkten ihm
die Kollegen eine Erinnerung:
die UBS in den Fängen der US-Justiz.
Manches hat sich geändert,
manches aber nicht.
Das Verhaltensmuster
der Credit Suisse heute
ist noch beleidigender als das,
was die UBS damals getan hat.
Die CS
hat ihre Lektion nicht gelernt.
Ob die US-Justiz
aktiv werden wird oder nicht,
lässt sich heute nicht sagen.
Ungemütlich ist die Situation
für CS und UBS auf jeden Fall.
Wie hoch könnten Bussen ausfallen?
Die Frage, wie viel die
Credit Suisse letztlich zahlen muss,
ist die 1-Mrd.-¤-Frage.
Wie hoch könnte diese Zahl sein?
Ich denke,
die Untergrenze liegt bei 1,3 Mrd.
und die Obergrenze
wahrscheinlich bei 3-5 Mrd. ¤.
Wer weiss das schon?
Urs Rohner
verabschiedet sich im April 2021
wegen Corona in einer virtuellen GV -
zwar mit einem Gewinn
von über 3 Mrd.,
aber auch mit weiteren Skandalen,
die ruchbar geworden sind.
Wir haben
unsere Kundinnen und Kunden,
aber auch unsere Aktionärinnen
und Aktionäre enttäuscht.
Und dies leider nicht zum ersten
Mal. Dafür entschuldige ich mich.
Der Aktienkurs ist unter Rohner
um über 70 % gefallen.
Kassiert hat er derweil
über 50 Mio. Fr.
Urs Rohner hat heute ein Büro
im Zürcher Seefeld.
Über einen Sprecher
lässt er Medien ausrichten,
er zahle nichts
von seinem Lohn zurück.
Herr Rohner, wieso zahlen Sie
die 52 Mio. nicht zurück?
António Horta-Osório, ein Portugiese,
übernimmt von Urs Rohner.
Meine Damen und Herren,
Mesdames et Messieurs ...
Er erbt von Rohner zwei weitere
Skandale: Archegos und Greensill.
Der Fall Archegos.
Beim Zusammenbruch von
Bill Hwangs Hedgefonds Archegos 2021
erlitt die CS
einen Verlust in Milliardenhöhe.
Im Dezember 2022
einigte sich die Bank mit Klägern.
Die endgültige gerichtliche
Genehmigung steht noch aus.
Zivilrechtliche Klagen sind hängig,
und weitere Rechtsstreitigkeiten
könnten drohen.
Der Fall Greensill.
Im Frühling 2021 brach der
Lieferkettenfonds Greensill zusammen.
Die Credit Suisse musste vier Fonds
von Greensill Capital einfrieren,
in die CS-Kunden
10 Mrd. ¤ investiert hatten.
Zivilklagen gegen die Bank
sind hängig, weitere könnten folgen.
Wo waren die Aufseher?
Was macht der Verwaltungsrat?
Was hat den Verwaltungsrat
dazu bewogen?
Er muss die Boni genehmigen.
Er zahlt die Boni. Die zahlt nicht
die Geschäftsleitung sich selbst.
Wieso hat er das so gehandhabt?
- Was glauben Sie?
Ich weiss nicht,
was sie gedacht haben.
Die CS
taumelt nun ihrem Ende entgegen.
Im Jahr 2022
schreibt sie nur noch Verluste.
Das Vertrauen in die Bank
ist verloren,
ihr Schicksal damit besiegelt.
Es fliesst immer mehr Geld ab,
bis der Bund im März 2023
die Notbremse zieht.
Die UBS schluckt die CS.
Und sie bekommt einen neuen Chef.
Ermottis Rückkehr -
der Bankenveteran
soll es bei der UBS wieder richten.
Ist er der Richtige für den Job?
Der Neue ist der Alte.
Schon 2011 hatte Sergio Ermotti
das Steuer der UBS übernommen -
nach Oswald Grübel.
Ich habe die UBS aufgeräumt.
Und der, der nach mir kommt,
kriegt fünfmal mehr Lohn.
Er setzt sich sozusagen
ins gemachte Bett.
Tut das heute noch weh?
- Nein, ich sage nur ...
Was wollen Sie da ändern?
Zürcher Sechseläuten 2013.
Heftige Kritik an Ermotti
wegen hoher Löhne und Boni.
Ich hoffe, ich bekomme Blumen.
Hoffentlich
bekomme ich keine Tomaten.
Ermottis neuer Fixlohn: 2,5 Mio. Fr.
Trotz staatlicher Garantien erhält er
einen Bonus. Höhe: unbekannt.
Klar ist: Die UBS ist jetzt so gross,
dass sie viel zu gross ist,
um noch fallen zu können.
Es ist einfach nicht gratis,
wenn man ein internationaler
Finanzplatz sein will.
Es tut mir leid. Sonst müssten man
sagen: Wir wollen das nicht mehr.
Aus historischen Betrachtungen
weiss man,
dass es immer wieder
Finanzkrisen gibt.
Man weiss nicht,
wann und wo und wen es genau trifft.
Aber dass es wieder kommt, ist klar.
Too big to fail
ist schlicht too big.
Wenn man im Ernst das Gefühl hat,
dass man mit 259 Mrd. bei
der nächsten UBS-Krise durchkommt,
dann sprechen wir von 2-3 Billionen.
Irgendwann
ruinieren wir die Schweiz.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Kira Euler, Daniela Zacheo - 2023